كنا ماشيين شفنا اليهود قدامنا والدبابات
شفنا يهودي اليهود قاعدين قاعدين بدخلوا
دي في واحد كن طلع فيهم عادي واحد قال لي
امشي ليه بتطلع فيه قلت له ايش يعني
خوفتني انت والله ما خفت منك و ابويا
ابويا ب خفس منه بس بخاف من ربنا رب
العالمين بس بخاف منه بس كانوا بيعملوا
الجمود كانوا قاعدين حصرنا اول حاجه
ارفعوا هواياتهم انا لسه صغير ماش هوايا
هويه ارفع عش هويه اخذوهم شفناهم ضربوا
فيهم وبوا فيهم قدام وفي ناس قاعدين
وقاعدين وحاصروا الشباب والاطفال الصغار
حصروا الشباب والنسوان كله حصلهم بس
النسوان يمشوا احنا ماشي انا وعادل اما
الشباب طل منروح الشباب يتحركوا انا قالوا
لي ارجع انا ما رضتش ارجع عن اضت ومشيت عد
يطرقوا رصاص علينا ما حدش خاف كله بدنك
وبيرفع ليلعبوا فينا لعبه قولوا اقعد اقعد
ارفع اقعد رفع الشارع ليه احنا لعبه حسبي
الله ونعم الوكيل بس
فيهم